marine est ce que vous connaissez la
chanson carnot star n'excluant next in
many marina qui danse non non non non
non non attendez jamais 11e très
mignonne ces dégâts
[Musique]
au parc à la fin
[Applaudissements]
ça sur internet quoi quoi c'est votre
copine qui avait jeudi en garde sans
vous aviez quel âge à présent 11 h 14
mais c'est sympa mais les deux tous
invités latine à la bm s'en va bien les
cheveux longs c'est comme moi j'aime
bien de carré plongeant 6 à l'autre
délire barcarès plage se souvient way
j'adore salvail permet un racleur h
parce que tu vois ça va comme ça ça
avance bien question bien sûr vous
l'avez entendu cette chanson
ça y est un carton elle a quasiment
dépassé les 3 milliards de vues combien
de clips ont dépassé la barre du
milliard de vues sur youtube ici ben 10
non plus d'une centaine centaine un
petit peu moins non 80% gaz non-russe
494 tout le moins 86 français louis 4 3
à 6 mois
[Applaudissements]
et le ferai